voter suppression laws
so the next race that has to happen is
in virginia you gotta pile up the
[ __ ] votes if you live in virginia
you have to [ __ ] vote you cannot
sacrifice your vote you have to [ __ ]
vote because your vote your vote is for
or against trump that's what your
[ __ ] mode is here
youncan in that state is a goddamn trump
pumping fool and he'll do anything to
get in
and if that means to bow down to trump
he'll do it
so if you want trumpy and [ __ ] in your
state
then go vote for yunkan because junkin
is trump yunkin is trump trump is yankin
in virginia he is trump trump trump
trump trump trump he's trump are you
going to vote for trump in virginia are
you going to vote for not trump
anti-trump
who cares who it is it's mcauliffe but
who cares it's not trump vote not trump
don't vote for trump which is junken
yunkin is trump we need to pound that in
everyone's brains that's what i'm saying
tweet it find a [ __ ] meme find a
[ __ ] video tweet tweet tweet tweet
tweet
that junkin is junking is trump tweet it
right now go tweet it junkins trump
junkins trump yonkin is trump junkin is
trump junkin is trump
go tweet